it was a was a certainly disappointing
result and i want to thank peter fleet
outstanding a local candidate but there
were particular circumstances
there and um we are getting on with
delivering our agenda for the whole
country that's what
one nation conservatism is all about
uh we believe in uh uniting and leveling
up
uh in within uh regions and across
across the country and you know i think
it's it's a bit
peculiar a bit bizarre uh to i i
won london twice i think i was elected
in henley uh twice and
and uh you know we just last month
uh we uh we we had gains in basildon and
maidstone in beijing stoke and uh all
over the place so you know we are a
great one nation party
and we will continue with our mission to
unite and level up because that is the
best way
to deliver jobs uh prosperity
across the whole country well one of
your backbenchers bob c
says the result is the start of a
significant push back on your planning
reforms
will you reconsider that in vital
results
i think there's some misunderstanding
about the
the planning reforms perhaps even some
willful misunderstanding
on part of some of our uh opponents but
uh
what i what we want is uh sensible
plans to allow development on brownfield
sites we don't want to be we're not
going to build on
uh greenbelt sites we're not going to
build on uh
all over the countryside but i do think
that uh the
young people growing up in this country
should have the the
chance of home ownership and that's what
we're focusing on
i think it's a great dream uh for young
people
uh in their in their 20s 30s that they
currently
don't have in the way that they perhaps
had
uh a few decades ago and that's
something that we want to bring back
we want to make it easier and that's
what we're all about
i'm bringing it a little closer um you
call matt
hancock hopeless do you still have full
faith in him
i have complete confidence in uh ma
and indeed the uh all of the government
who've been
uh dealing with covered throughout the
pandemic and i think that
uh when you look at the vaccine rollout
that has been delivered by the nhs it is
absolutely
outstanding and i would just remind you
that uh
today uh under the leadership of
of ma and the nhs where now we've now
done i think 80 percent
of adults in this country have had a
first jab and we're now asking
uh 18 year olds uh to come forward so
we're making huge huge progress and
that's down to
uh the work of the nhs and
with with matt at the top of it and on
that now all agencies all over 80s
are being called for their job today but
also in kirklees there's a
15 rise still happening here can you
guarantee that all remaining
restrictions
will be lifted on july 19th we are i'm
very confident that we'll be able to go
through with uh
step four of the of the road map uh
on the timetable that i've set out with
treating
july the 19th as i've said there's a
terminus date i think that's
uh that's that's certainly what the data
continues to to indicate
well as you know country very excited by
the u.s today
will you really allow thousands of fans
and vips into the uk for the u.s
semi-finals
and the finals i mean uaf are pushing
for fans to be exempt too
will you really allow that we'll do what
we have to do
to uh to keep the country safe from from
cover that's obviously going to be
our priority uh and uh you know we'll be
talking to
to ua for about what they uh what they
want and and see if we can make some
some sensible accommodations uh but the
priority obviously has to be
has to be public health i'm just
slightly moving away from that
how worried are you by the situation in
northern ireland at the moment
can give and really continue as first
minister under these circumstances
i think that it's very important that
the
northern ireland government should be
stable it should
enjoy support from
across parties uh which it does and
that's good it's back up and
uh and running and what we want to do is
as the uk is
ensure that we look after the stability
of northern the peace process
uh and of course uh the union and
uh and movement of goods people services
and capital
uh between all parts of the union and
that's what we're going to do